[Musique]
il
bonjour bienvenue au parlement européen
à bruxelles pour un nouveau numéro d'
europe hebdo et cette semaine on
s'intéresse sont revenus extérieurs des
députés européens les possibles conflits
d'intérêts on en a beaucoup parlé lors
de l'audition de sylvie goulard
candidate à la commission européenne
retoqué notre reportage avec les ong
transparency international un soupçon de
conflit d'intérêts au parlement européen
30% des députés européens ont des
activités rémunérées en plus de leur
mandat et vous allez le voir il est très
difficile de savoir de prouver ainsi
lien conflit d'intérêts entre ses
activités extérieures et son mandat de
député européen les ong réclament la
création d'une autorité chargée de
veiller à la transparence de la vie
publique dans les institutions
européennes sur ce plateau monjoin 3
invité sylvie guillaume bonjour vous
êtes eurodéputés socialistes depuis 2009
free lui en mai dernier à vous avez été
et ça intéresse notre sujet
vice-présidente du parlement européen
lors de la précédente législature
merci d'être venus manon aubry bonjour
vous êtes députée européenne du groupe
de la gauche unitaire européenne ici au
parlement européen tout nouvel élu en
mai dernier élu sous les couleurs de la
france a soumises merci d'avoir accepté
merci mon invitation enfin jean
quatremer à merci d'être venu à vous est
le correspondant du journal libération
ici à bruxelles ça fait 30 ans que vous
sévissez ici et vous n'avez toujours pas
été retoqué vous on vient de nous et ses
revenus extérieurs alors juste une
précision
juste une précision on a essayé
d'invités avoue une eurodéputée du
groupe renault en europe le groupe de
sylvie goulard impossible à ils étaient
tous en réunion de groupe
à francfort alors avant d'aborder notre
dossier un mot sur le goudargues et 1 au
terme d'une deuxième audition les
eurodéputés ont rejeté jeudi dernier la
candidature par 82 voix contre 29 et une
abstention un civil boulard a longuement
été interrogé sur la sphère des emplois
fictifs au parlement et sur ses
activités rémunérées 10000 euros par
mois par une fondation américaine alors
qu'elle était eurodéputés on regarde on
réagit juste après
[Musique]
coup de tonnerre au parlement européen
la candidature de sylvie goulard choisi
par emmanuel macron pour devenir
commissaire est rejetée par les
eurodéputés
par 82 voix contre 29 dans un tweet
sylvie goulard prend acte de la décision
je prends acte de la décision du
parlement européen dans le respect de la
démocratie
je remercie le président de la
république et ursula von der leyen pour
leur confiance et tous les députés qui
ont voté pour moi
dans sa dernière audition jeudi dernier
les parlementaires pointer à nouveau les
deux enquêtes dont elle fait l'objet
son travail pour un film tant
qu'américains alors qu'elle était
députée européenne c'est l'eurodéputé
français soumise manuel bompard qui
prend la parole et la sphère des emplois
présumés fictifs au modem qui avait
déclenché son départ du gouvernement
damien carême pour les verts interpelle
sylvie goulard pourquoi
et pourquoi comment votre situation
personnelle n'aurait-elle pas de
conséquences sur votre action comme
commissaire ne serait ce pas une manière
de créer un problème pour toute la
commission européenne dans un moment si
décisive pour l'europe
moi la seule chose que je vous demande
c'est que vous jugiez une personne un
parcours vous avez dit monsieur bel ami
que vous n'étiez pas là pour juger
peut-être que vous évaluez
personnellement je trouve que ce mandat
est exaltant j'espère que vous me
donnerez la chance de l'exercer aux
côtés de madame federline sylvie goulard
retoqué à un camouflet pour emmanuel
macron qui avait pris le risque de la
choisir malgré les affaires malgré les
assurances qu'il avait reçu aussi moi je
me suis battu pour un portefeuille
j'ai soumis trois noms on m'a dit votre
nom une formidable on prend et puis à la
fin j'ai finalement n'en veut plus les
mêmes donc il faut il faut qu'on
m'explique
chez les eurodéputés il ya ceux qui
regrettent une candidate qui s'est
toujours battu pour l'europe
je la connais bien elle se bat depuis
des décennies depuis 30 ans pour pour
l'europe et je lui accorde sept
cette bonne foi et il ya ceux pour qui
cette candidature était vouée à l'échec
il y avait un conflit d'intérêts il y
avait un problème judiciaire même si
elle est toujours innocentes en suspens
et puis surtout il ya une maladresse
énorme de macron qui a donné je répète
l'impression à tous les députés
européens que finalement ils étaient
j'allais dire la deuxième division et
qu'on pouvait envoyer ce qu'on voulait
pas au gouvernement français on pouvait
l'envoyer à l'union européenne
et le temps presse la nouvelle
commission est censée entrer en fonction
le 1er novembre
même si un report est désormais
envisagée
[Musique]
voilà la candidature de sylvie goulard a
essuyé un rejet cinglant des euro
députés comment vous l'expliquez ses
divisions je crois qu'on a fait un peu
le tour de la question il ya une
attitude personnelle de la candidate
il ya cette façon effectivement que le
président de la république française à
de considérer siffle finalement c'est
une formalité que tout ce qui pourrait
être reproché à la candidate n'a pas
d'importance du moment qu'il a une main
mise sur la décision et moi il ya deux
doses autre chose qui me semble
extrêmement inquiétante et qui je crois
vont marquer une certaine manière comme
une phase fondamentale institutionnel et
politique
c'est que 1 on n'interroge pas par
exemple la candidate sur qu'est ce
qu'elle va faire dans son portefeuille
quand on a la défense le spatial le
marché unique le numérique sur son
rapport aux lobbys on y viendra
peut-être mais qu'est ce qu'elle se
réfugie derrière il ya une règle qui est
celle de la commission européenne depuis
2014 où on ne rend compte que des lobbys
qui sont inscrits sur le registre de
transparence ça ne suffit pas sur ce
type de dossier c'est évidemment
fondamental et deuxièmement je trouve
que franchement le portefeuille français
tel qu'il est peut interroger un certain
nombre de partenaires européens c'est
très vaste il faut une maîtrise
d'énormément de dossier et je ne suis
pas sûr que cette candidate avait
réellement cette technique vallandry un
camouflet adressé à emmanuel macron mais
je crois que c'est un camouflet mais qui
était pas évident il faut le dire parce
que quand on a commencé la bataille nous
d'abord en commission des affaires
juridiques à ce moment là il y avait que
quelques républicains français avec nous
et j'ai beaucoup d'amitié pour les
socialistes français mais le groupe
socialiste a défendu pendant plusieurs
réunions et en réunion coordination
sylvie goulard avant pour la plupart
d'entre eux le jour même de ne pas voter
en sa faveur en réunion des
coordinateurs j'ai assisté aux réunions
des coordinateurs notamment en
commission des affaires juridiques et là
le représentant socialiste a défendu
sylvie goulard mais je pense qu'il faut
tirer des leçons
il faut tirer des leçons on revient avec
le coordinateur socialiste tout à fait
s'il ya des désaccords au sein de votre
groupe
c'est regrettable mais c'est une chose
mais il faut aussi aller par plusieurs
leçons de cette séquence
la première c'est d'abord que l'analyse
et l'examen des conflits d'intérêts au
sein du gouvernement au sein du
des institutions européennes n'a pas
complètement fonctionné parce qu'elle a
passé cette première étape
on va en parler alors qu'elle n'aurait
pas dû passer cette première étape est
la deuxième chose c'est la réaction des
manuels macron c'est vraiment c'est un
peu comme un enfant à qui on a enlevé
son jouet en fait
et qui dit moi je comprends pas ce
rendez moi mon jouet est en fait j'ai
envie de lui dire ma bienvenue en
démocratie il ne peut pas faire à
bruxelles ce qu'il fait à paris il ne
peut pas imposer des décisions
représentants au parlement européen et
je trouve que c'est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle que le parlement européen des
ministres une certaine indépendance dans
la prise de décision même si il y à du
jeu politique là dedans il faut le
reconnaître et la dernière leçon que je
vais tirer c'est que j'espère que ça va
nous permettre de changer les règles du
parlement européen et d'interdire les
sources des rémunérations alex parce que
derrière tout ça il ya l'immoralité de
quand on est député est déjà plutôt bien
rémunéré de toucher des sommes annexes
et de répondre à des intérêts privés
jean quatremer le parlement européen
sort renforcée de cette histoire oui il
se renforcer mais il a déjà été géré
c'est pas la première fois que le
parlement européen rejette des candidats
en deux en 2004 il a rejeté deux
candidats dont com diary tallien ensuite
en 2009 il en a rejeté un en 2014 aucun
et cette fois ci 3 donc c'est pas très
nouveau que le parlement européen joue
son rôle de contrôle démocratique
non je trouve que ça interroge beaucoup
cette affaire fait il ya deux des onze
personnes surtout chez makro je vais pas
y revenir
emmanuel macron parce que il était
effectivement dominant au sein de
l'union européenne depuis le mois de
juillet où il avait réussi à imposer
l'ensemble de ses candidats aux
différentes aux différents postes de
direction de l'union européenne donc
c'est extraordinaire et puis dans ce
quiz et à nouveau il se plante et impôts
la question de emmanuel macron directeur
des ressources humaines parce qu'on ne
se rappeler qu'avant
sylvie goulard alors que tout le monde
lui avait dit dans son entourage ses
alliés politiques
nolan ne la désigne pas parce qu' elle
ne va pas passer l'étape du parlement
européen
il a quand même il y a été parce que
j'ai parlé une arrogance une
incompréhension je ne sais pas mais
avant ça il y avait eu nathalie les
oiseaux quand même qui avait été quand
même une erreur de casting monumentale
de nommer nathalie oiseaux comme tête de
liste dans marche ça a été un miracle
que en marche se tiennent bien pendant
toute la campagne dire qu'il a fallu
beaucoup de gens ont été votés on vote
en marche en dépit de nathalie l'oiseau
qui
ça va qu'il y avait un côté mais c'est
cette espèce de d'élite méprisante qui
ne qui avait du mal à passer
deuxième chose c'est celle à von der
leyen faut pas l'oublier dans le tableau
est ce que c'est la fin des laguiole
c'est elle qui adore de la commission
will présent la commission allemande
donc c'est la candidate emmanuel macron
aussi donc quelque part le drh macron
qui est quand même mis en cause
c'est elle qui a taillé ce portefeuille
pour sylvie goulard c'est elle qui a
soutenu
sylvie goulard comme candidate c'est
quand même sa candidate aussi sinon on
aurait pu dire à emmanuel macron
coutelle à des affaires dont je peux pas
la prendre c'est déjà arrivé dans le
passé car présente commission rejette en
amont un candidat est là elle est quand
même et sévèrement atteintes
ce qui veut dire que à mon avis elle est
affaiblie si elle passe parce que je
suis pas du tout certain maintenant que
la nouvelle coalition sur sa voix la
candidature elle-même
voilà je pense que là elle est très
affaiblie donc si jamais elle passe elle
sera entre les mains du parlement
européen c'est de ce point de vue là
c'est l'affaiblissement institutionnel
de la commission qui fait que ça va
renforcer le parlement européen et le
contrôle du parlement européen sur la
commission sur quoi cela va déboucher je
n'en sais strictement rien
on peut célébrer la démocratie c'est
très bien mais on peut aussi s'inquiéter
du fait que plus personne ne peut savoir
ce qui va se passer dans les mois dans
l'est la nouvelle admission donc très
probablement le 1er décembre prochain
qui pour remplacer sylvie goulard
l'apéro l'osar on parle de florence
parly écoutez il faut être sérieux
michel barnier c'est un homme du passé
ségolène royal faut pas plaisanter je
veux dire on va se ridiculiser nouvelle
fois en europe ça va quoi florence parly
elle a dit non deux trois ou quatre fois
donc danse avec quelqu'un d'autre et la
crise le problème c'est que ça risque de
ne pas être une femme parce que le
parlement européen a tué une femme et la
france peut dire écoutez moi maintenant
voilà mes autres candidats vous aurez
c'est à elle ou untel vous aurez noté
que le président la réplique française
dit j'ai proposé des noms et après
finalement les noms ne m'intéresse pas
ce qui m'intéresse c'est le portefeuille
et j'y reviens cette question des
portefeuilles cette question reste
entière
il est trop grand il est inadapté c'est
un poste de fer gigantesque par rapport
aux rapports de force dans l'union
vis-à-vis des commissaires et ça pose
réellement problème c'est un problème de
contrôle sur d'autres commissaires dans
tous les cas on espère qu'il sera un peu
plus vigilant d'un point de vue éthique
ils on verra on va passer à notre
enquête au parlement européen la lutte
contre les conflits d'intérêt reste
balbutiante
un tiers des 751 eurodéputés élus en mai
ont des activités rémunérées en dehors
de leur mandat ils obéissent à un code
de conduite très peu dissuasif
on regarde leur portage et ont réagi
juste après bruxelles son parlement
européen
c'est 751 députés ou salaire plus que
confortable
huit mille 700 euros brut par mois des
députés européens qui ont tout de même
le droit de travailler ailleurs et
percevoir des revenus extérieurs
pourvu qu'ils s'en tiennent au code de
conduite
la règle c'est qu'il n'y a pas
d'interdiction à avoir une autre
activité ou un revenu additionnel à la
condition qu'il n'y ait pas de conflit
d'intérêts c'est que cette activité
n'entraîne pas un conflit d'intérêt avec
votre activité de député
par exemple pouvait pas prendre des
textes législatifs sur l'industrie du
pétrole et travailler géant pétrolier va
ça c'est absolument pas monsieur pas de
conflit d'intérêts
seulement voilà le système au parlement
européen est un peu trop permissifs en
matière de rémunération externe
raphaël kergo notre travail pour l' ong
transparency international il a collecté
les déclarations de revenus de tous les
eurodéputés elle son public sur le site
du parlement européen
résultat un tiers des eurodéputés de la
nouvelle assemblée élue en mai ont gardé
une activité rémunérée en supplément par
lieu 48 ont déclaré un revenu annuel
supérieur à leur salaire de
parlementaire
parmi les dix élus qui gagne le mieux
leur vie en dehors de l'hémicycle des
gains allant de 240 milles à 960 mille
euros par an 500 britanniques et tous
issus du break 6 2 parties y compris
leur chef de file
nigel farrage en cinquième place de
cette étude
le belge guy verhofstadt ancien premier
ministre
le premier français est en 14e position
l'élu du rassemblement national jérôme
rivière de là à ce qu'il y ait conflit
d'intérêts impossible à savoir les
descriptions des fonctions leur
garantissant leurs revenus
supplémentaires font parfois trop vague
souvent les descriptions des activités
elle même ce ne sont pas précise on a
trouvé des députés qui rapporte juste
avocat sans savoir pour quels cabinets
d'avocats dans quel domaine économique
ont agi consultants et nous allons même
un député qui a juste marqué activités
économiques 5000 à 10000 euros et le
problème de 2,2 quand on marque des
activités qui ne sont pas précise enfin
des descriptions qui sont pas précise ça
nous permet pas de savoir s'il ya
potentiellement un conflit d'intérêt ou
pas et s'il ya conflit d'intérêts le
code de conduite n'est que très peu
dissuasif s'il ya doute le président du
parlement peut saisir un comité
consultatif sur la conduite des députés
formé de cinq eurodéputés
au cours de la précédente législature un
total de 24 violation du code de
conduite a été signalé
mais aucune sanction n'a été prononcée
par le président aujourd'hui
le problème c'est qu'on avait un comité
déontologique qui n'a pas fait son
travail de sanctionner et de demander
des comptes
quand vous voyez qu'il ya une
rétribution important d'un député qui
viennent l'extérieur
le minimum c'est de savoir d'où ça vient
est-ce que ça vienne d'un lobby c'est ce
que ça vient d'une boîte qui avait fondé
le député enfin je veux dire ça c'est de
la transparence
emmanuel foule on travaille depuis dix
ans parlement européen et des conflits
d'intérêts concernant des eurodéputés il
en a vu pas mal dans sa carrière lors du
mandat précédent on avait rachida dati
qui faisait partie de la commission
entreprises et énergie mais qui à côté
de son salaire de député européenne
touché un salaire de plus de 10000 euros
pour être entre autre avocate et que
parmi sa liste de clients
il y avait des entreprises qui étaient
liés à l'énergie des entreprises qui
étaient impactés par ces prises de
décisions au sein du parlement européen
alors évidemment que ça jette le doute
et ça jette le doute sur son travail à
elle mais de manière générale à toutes
les instances des institutions
européennes donc je pense qu'il ya
quelque chose à faire au sein du
parlement européen cède la commission
européenne aussi et puis quand ce qui
est légal mais pas éthique du tout alors
il est peut-être temps de changer la loi
changer la loi c'est l'avis de
l'eurodéputé allemand daniel fronde il
travaillait chez transparency
international jusqu'à cet été
il a une proposition ouais je vais
proposer qu'on met une limite maximale
des revenus qu'on peut avoir en externe
pour hériter justement qu'il ya des
conflits d'intérêts et on s'est basé sur
l'exemple qui existe déjà au parlement
aux états unis où les revenus externes
sont limitées à 15 % du salaire des
députés
et moi je pensais c'est une bonne
proposition
autre proposition la création d'un
comité d'éthique indépendant pour
l'ensemble des institutions européennes
en attendant et contrairement au
commissaire européen aux fonctionnaires
ou même aux assistants parlementaires
un député européen qui quitte son mandat
peut toujours travailler chez un
lobbyiste ou autre là aussi il n'y a pas
de règle
[Musique]
voilà quand vous regardez ce reportage
vous dites quoi c'est impossible de
déceler un conflit d'intérêts au
parlement européen dans les règles
actuelles non dans les règles actuelles
les informations qui sont demandées sont
extrêmement insuffisante pour déceler un
potentiel conflit d'intérêt
pour la petite anecdote nous en tant que
députés français élus de la france on
doit donner plus d'informations à la
haute autorité de la transparence de la
vie publique en france qu'aux
institutions européennes donc à tout le
moins il faudrait un cadre similaire et
ça pousse aussi la nécessité d'une
autorité indépendante parce que à
l'heure actuelle le problème c'est que
l'examen des conflits d'intérêts pour
les commissaires déjà ce fait 100 ans
sans moyens et sans indépendance
vous avez ce premier problème là pour
les commissaires et pour les
parlementaires européens
alors là c'est le no man's land ont
globalement ils font ce qu'ils veulent
et en plus de je ne sais pas où est ce
qu'ils trouvent le temps d'avoir une
activité annexe
il ya vraiment un côté indécent et
immoral vis-à-vis des citoyens qui nous
ont élus à accepter une forme des
rémunérations qui vient de l'extérieur
et qui plus est quand ça vient d'un
cadre privé d'un institut privé d'un
lobby est forcément à la fin on répond
davantage aux intérêts des lobbys qu aux
intérêts de des citoyens et donc moi je
vais on en discute beaucoup avec les
verts pour faire une proposition
conjointe de réguler en parler mais on
aimerait aller plus loin même que limité
à 15% la part de rémunérations annexes
en interdisant certaines activités
annexes qui n'ont pas leur place quand
on est un député élu
chacun dans nos pays et répondant aux
intérêts des électeurs et des citoyens
je pense qu'il faut aller
d'après joe carrément les certaines
activités par exemple les revenus
extérieurs
alors oui et je pense qu'il faut
réfléchir à différents types d'activités
et ça se fait d'ailleurs aux états unis
autorisent et éventuellement de
l'enseignement ou des droits d'auteurs
dans une certaine limite financière et
interdire des sources de rémunération à
neige quand ça vient par exemple un
groupe d'intérêts privés ou dans l'aude
où il faut regarder un petit peu la
liste à ces super intéressant parce que
notamment 1 0 des publiait le plus à
députés l eurodéputé polonais qui
s'appelle sikorski je rappelle que quand
même lui il était tombé dans une dans un
piège qui a été tendu par la presse
britannique à quelques années où il est
proposé de le rémunérer pour déposer des
amendements et il avait dit vous
ça avait été filmé ça avait fait un
scandale majeur il ya trois eurodéputés
qui était tombé dans ce piège
on les joue je considère qu'aujourd'hui
si on n'a pas à faire ce genre attendent
ce genre de pièce piège aux eurodéputés
mais ça en dit long
il gagne chaque année en plus de son
revenu d'eurodéputé je crois que cela en
est ça doit être aux alentours de 80
mille euros par an net j'imagine 70000
80 euros lui gagne neuf cent soixante
mille euros de plus par an dire qu'il ya
des gens alors elle quand on regarde en
plus alors les partis politiques
ça c'est intéressant parce
qu'effectivement on a cité deux à
l'heure guy verhofstadt on l'a vu guy
verhofstadt qui siège à peu près dans
entre 5 et 10 conseils d'administration
rexie deux parties aussi la halde a
admis dans quelle est donc pour 15000
euros par mois mais les partis qui se
met le plus d'argent dans la poche ce
sont les partis qui soit disant défendre
le peuple c'est tous les partis
eurosceptiques populis le front national
alors là un nombre de députés du front
national 10 ans met un maximum dans la
poche on l'a vu jérôme rivière tout à
l'heure et ces braves gens qui se gagne
qui ce qui se sait vraiment qui se
goinfrent à la fois dans le privé et au
sein du parlement européen qui aussi
mettre la main dans le pot de confiture
avec la sphère d'aidé en repiquant
l'argent du parlement européen je vous
rappelle quand même la sphère des
assistants parlementaires européens du
du rassemblement la saga qui n'a
toujours pas été jugé d'ailleurs dire
que c'est c'est incroyable et les gens
continuent à voter pour des courses et
pour pour ces partis qui se gonflent en
afrique
vous en avez vu des conflits d'alembert
et pendant le conflit d'intérêt au cours
de votre carrière
on soit quelqu'un que les activités
extérieures je sais rien je suis
journaliste je peux faire georges est
légal ils ont le maire je me suis
journaliste peut faire que je révise
vous aussi d'ailleurs on a les exigences
sans doute très limité moi je pense que
quelqu'un qui est eurodéputé et qui fait
son travail il n'a pas le temps de faire
autre chose à écrire des bouquins si
sans doute pendant les vacances
avoir des droits d'auteur etc etc ça il
peut faire ça mais des gens qui
prétendent être à la fois avocat et
parlementaire européen
ça n'est juste pas possible personne
n'est obligé de se faire élire député
européen je dis bien personne
si vous
foncez vite qu on fume je suis résident
au canada dessus je suis tout à fait
d'accord sur le fait qu' on peut pas
considérer le boulot la fonction de
député européen comme étant un truc
marginal par rapport à une autre
activité puisse cumuler avec moi je ne
sais pas comment ces gens font et ça
veut dire que d'une certaine manière ils
décident qu'ils ne sont pas législateur
qui ne s'occupent pas d'aussi est
réellement important qui bosse pas
réellement dans le cadre du parlement
européen et donc ça vaut ça renvoie
aussi à une certaine attitude assez
française où on considère que le
parlement européen cette voie de garage
pour un certain nombre de personnes qui
attendent autre chose
on a quand même quelques exemples assez
partagée d'ailleurs sauvé formation
politique dans cette maison dans petit 1
je crois vraiment qu'il faut se
consacrer au mandat 2 ça dépend si on
veut réglementer il faut qu'on règlement
correctement effectivement des droits
d'auteurs ou de l'enseignement je
considère que c'est extrêmement
différents encore que certains ont des
droits d'auteur ou pas apparemment
d'après ce que ce que j'ai vu
troisièmement il ya la capacité dans le
comité consultatif de faire dans votre
reportage de faire une sorte d' enquête
ce que vous ce à quoi vous avez fait
allusion tout à l'heure c'est la
capacité de jury de la commission jury
en initial sa première fois que jury
fait ça donc il faut évidemment donner
plus de pouvoirs à ce que jury puisse
mieux mieux les affaires juridiques par
la dgta mais simplement
mais le comité consultatif qui a repéré
des conflits d'intérêts et qui est là à
pouvoir d' enquête abandonnée transmet
au président et président qu'est ce
qu'il a fait ces dernières années au
culte champalaune et il n'a pas la lune
glisse l'élu dans six vice-présidents 10
à 8
vous n'avez oui c'est même là tu as
entendu simplement les vice présidents
du parlement européen ne sont pas dans
le comité consultatif handball et ne
prennent pas la décision c'est le
président seul qui les revend
l'expliquer il faut changer d'absents
pour l'instant la règle est celle ci pas
je pense que le président précédent et
peut-être le précédent encore ont pas
voulu faire de vacances il s'agissait
d'un tag au tac
donc il faut pas que ça soit dans la
mains d'une seule personne à l'aide d'un
seul homme ou d'une seule personne
donc ce comité travaille à mon avis
qu'il a plutôt fait bien son boulot il a
repéré des choses qui n'étaient pas
acceptables
elles m'ont donné ses portes et au
président philippe ben finalement pas
faire de vagues il faut que ça change
et le voilà même en fait c'est qu'il ya
un conflit d'intérêts dans l'est
des conflits d'intérêts moi je les vues
au sein de la commission des affaires
juridiques vous demandez à des députés
qui appartiennent à des camps politiques
à des groupes politiques de défendre ou
descendre un député de l'eure même
groupe politique est là c'est pour ça
que ça pose un problème fondamental
d'indépendance et ça pousse à la
nécessité de la création d'une autorité
indépendante qui serait en charge de
l'examen et de l'analyse et de l'enquète
et d'investigation potentiel quand c'est
nécessaire les dans votre pardon
d'oriental dans votre registre ça veut
dire que la nouvelle formule de la
commission juridique qui examine le
conflit d'intérêts au démarrage il a
l'air plus de la plus de pouvoir je
pense que la collision des affaires
juridiques faut qu'elle soit associée en
dit en donnant des lignes directrices
notamment qu'est ce qui est considéré
comme un conflit d'intérêt ou pas parce
que la définition est encore fait assez
floue et même son nom aux gens qui nous
regardent les ismes et conflits
d'intérêts c'est quoi et au bout d'un
moment il faut un cadre indépendant avec
des personnes auxquelles vous croyez à
l'indépendance parce que on s'est
retrouvé moins pour avoir assisté aux
débats honnêtement dans des débats
lunaire vous avez la droite qui défend
les candidats du ppe donc le groupe
européen de la droite les socialistes
qui défend des socialistes ou alors
qu'ils sont mal à l'aise on essaie de
les protéger en demandant un vote secret
enfin ça c'est complètement lunaire et
je le dis d'autant plus que moi je suis
à l'aise en faisant partie d'un groupe
qui n'avait pas de candidat de
commissaires mais je dis pas pour autant
que c'est à moi de décider
et à mon groupe de décider jeudi jusqu'à
un conflit d'intérêt dans l'examen mal
et des chantiers dans je pense qu'il
faut distinguer très clairement les
activités extérieures du conflit
d'intérêts d'abord pour avoir des
conflits d'intérêts sans être payés
staff à dire qu'il ya des gens qui sont
ici dans ce parlement qui sont le
porte-voix de lobby et on voit bien les
amendements qui ont été déposés par
exemple les avez des exemples créatif
s'est écoulé elle a déposé des
amendements aux directives bancaires qui
étaient des amendements qui était porté
par le lobby bancaire allemand c'est une
réalité voilà et des gens comme ça donc
déjà ça c'est un conflit d'intérêts qui
pourraient être réglés par cette
autorité indépendante mais je pense que
plus généralement c'est des activités
annexes en soi qui à mon avis sont
porteuses de conflit d'intérêts il faut
donc les interdire ou les réglementer ou
les limites et moi je suis désolé mais
tant que c'est autorisé
oui a lui même théorisé un climat vos
car maintenant c'est juste pas possible
c'est des enjeux d'anthologie comme pas
possible échange maryse
les arguments l'argument habituel que
j'entends tout le temps c'est mais vous
comprenez parce que moi je suis dans le
privé et donc il faut que je puisse
revenir dans le privé à la sortie est
alors moi je connais des médecins par
exemple qui est ce qu'ils font eh bien
ils vont travailler une fois par semaine
dans leur hôpital gratuitement voilà un
avocat il va faire un truc dingue
l'avocat d'affaires il va faire du pro
deo gratuit il va aller défendre les
pour est comme ça pendant cinq ans dire
que ça parce que l'église les avocats
j'ai rien contre en particulier mais ils
ont ou look et l'accord
interinstitutionnel qu'on était en train
de négocier avec la commission et le
conseil sur le registre de transparence
parce que leur situation n'était pas
compatible avec ces discussions est
alors révolutionnaire la c4 au et
notamment les avocats qui étaient bien
représentés dans cette discussion à
terre institutionnels ont bloqué ce
dispositif aura fait depuis juillet
dernier les eurodéputés doivent déclarer
leur rendez vous avec des lobbys
uniquement les rapporteurs les verra les
rapporteurs les présidents de commission
donc lors d'une négociation sur un texte
législatif est ce que ça marche mais
c'est pas dit c'est que l'ensemble des
déportés donc si vous voulez moi quand
j'arrive ici au parlement - il se trouve
que je rende public mon agenda chaque
semaine mais pour n'importe lequel des
751 est sollicité par des lobbys vous
met en permanence matin que j'en ai fait
une vidéo hebdomadaire ou le coin des
lobbys et je m'amuse à sélectionner
chaque semaine l'ambassade d'arabie
saoudite qui insistent et qui veut
parler à quel point la vente d'armes et
bien le dire c'est bien ça ça prouve
comment l'arabie saoudite parle aux
femmes
oui c'est exactement ce que je devrais
la réponse la business europe qui est
l'équivalent du medef européen qui veut
nous dire à quel point baisser les
impôts des grandes entreprises c'est
formidable des climato sceptiques à
l'appel à la pelle qui nous disent à
quel point le changement climatique
n'est pas une réalité on est submergé et
pourtant en étant président du groupe de
la gauche européenne je pense que
j'étais pas forcément la cible
privilégiée
alors j'imagine pour ceux qui sont au
centre est très rapidement les solutions
donc plein demande et des revenus
additionnels 15% ou internet est créé
création d'une haute autorité de
transparence de la vie publique à la
française pour les institutions
européennes à président de la commission
le veut c'est bon ou alors interdiction
carrément vous
c'était pas gagné quand on a demandé un
débat à ce que se tienne un débat sur le
sujet en session plénière
l'ensemble des groupes au début étaient
opposés on a réussi à l'arracher
maintenant de là ce qu'on obtienne un
accord on va se battre pour cette
autorité indépendante et pour cette 1ère
interdiction des rémunérations annexes
mais j'espère que les autres groupes qui
ont beaucoup parlé vont voter quand il
s'agira de mettre en place et ces
mesures et puis on peut trouver aussi
d'autres choses on peut compléter aussi
tout cela il ya ce qu'ils appellent une
empreinte législatif quand vous êtes
rapporteur et que vous rencontrez des
gens pour former votre point de vue ce
qui a priori n'est pas critiquable en
soi il faut que vous puissiez au bout
indiqué qu'ils vous avez vu et commence
à influer sur votre décision
voilà ça fait partie des choses aussi
qu'on peut développer ce sera le mot de
la fin
merci à vous de moi d'avoir accepté mon
invitation c'était très instructif merci
à vous de nous avoir suivis et bonne
suite des programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires
[Musique]